hey guys my name is just McDonald today
is the 30th of sep tember and you're
tuned into guess what news it's another
day and another Assassin's Creed game
yes that's right another one as if you
we weren't doing enough assassin stuff
with unity on new gen consoles rogue on
last gen the Assassin's Creed America's
collection and recently assassin's creed
chronicles china popping up in the unity
dlc now we'll get assassin's creed
identity identity has already launched
right here in australia but it's set for
release in the US soon the action RPG is
a free-to-play iOS game presented in
third person 3d view and though it
features microtransactions they are
limited to character customization and
vanity items there are three classes
solid visuals and a storyline set during
the Italian Renaissance and I'm pretty
sure I lost most of you at free-to-play
iOS game so let's move on from that one
for now which a dev CD Projekt RED are
reaffirming why they hate drm and games
seem to be pretty much on board with it
me hablas off gilles told IGN that in
regard to drm they don't want to assault
anyone he explained each time we're
thinking about a decision the first rule
is we have to treat game is like we'd
like to be treated we don't believe in
drm because we hate drm it also doesn't
protect not really games are cracked in
minutes hours or days but they're always
cracked if you want to pirate you'll
find a way but if you're a committed
gamer enter buying the game why should
we place a barrier on you he also went
to speak out about DLC which he claims
is problematic since often the content
gamers are getting for their money is
insignificant in things that are
confusing Microsoft has announced that
Windows 10 will be following windows 8
furthering the suspicion that counting
is not the company's strong suit when
those 9 has faded into obsolescence
because Marco soft want to enforce that
10 is the last major update and all
future changes will come in smaller
updates to the windows 10 codebase
Windows 10 is doing away with the
unpopular Metro tile interface from
Windows a
and will run on a load of different
devices Microsoft's Windows exact Joe
belfer said we want all these Windows 7
users to have the sentiments that
yesterday they were driving a first
generation Prius and now with Windows 10
it's like we got the Methuselah ask you
a question of the day let me know if you
reckon Ubisoft need to slow down on the
Assassin's Creed games and whether or
not you liked Windows 8 those are all
the things I wanted to tell you about
today i'll be back same time and place
tomorrow but be sure to have yourself a
wonderful day until then